OF THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE
IF EVERYONE COULD PLEASE TURN
OFF THEIR CELL PHONES AND TO
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE SO WE CAN
HEAR TESTIMONY. WE HAVE ONE
ITEM BEFORE US TODAY BE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH WE
HEARD IN PAST PREVIOUSLY AFTER
THE GOVERNOR TO FINANCE
COMMITTEE THE TWO COMMITTEES
WORK TOGETHER WITH THE AUTHOR.
TO MAKE SOME MODIFICATIONS ARE
TO THE BILL AND I THINK
PRODUCED A VERY GOOD OUR
PRODUCT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS A SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND THE STAFFS OF BOTH
HOUSING INCOME AND FINANCE
COMMITTEES AS WELL AS REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY. TO PRODUCE
WHAT I THINK IS A VERY GOOD
FILLED IT DOES HAVE MY A
POSITIVE RECOMMENDATION. SO.
WITH THAT WE WILL SO. WARM.
THIRTY WIENER PRESENT PRESENT
MORRELL. BATES BATES PRESENT
COVER. CABALLERO PRESENT DORADO
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HERE MARLA.
WELL I PRESENT ROTH BOB PRESENT
SKINNER AMBERG THE CASKET I
GUESS HE PRESENT OKAY WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'LL CALL YOU BE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. THE
MERGER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU SENATORS
SALARY JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND FINE IF YOU WANT
TO HAVE DINNER TONIGHT IT'S ON
ME. I'M HAPPY TO BE BACK
PRESENTING THIS BILL TO AND I
WANNA JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND
ESPECIALLY SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR
YOUR DEEP ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
AND HELPING US TO CHART. A
NONTRADITIONAL PATH FOR THIS
BILL AS A REFRESHER AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IS A REGIONAL BEAR
A BILL TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE BAY AREA REGION.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL HAS
BEEN TO ENABLE THE BAY AREA TO
HELP ITSELF TO GIVE OUR NINE
COUNTY REGION THE AUTHORITY TO
RAISE FUNDING. FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SIMILAR TO HOW OUR
REGION HAS LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY TO RAISE MONIES FOR
TRANSPORTATION. AS WELL AS FOR
RESTORATION OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY.THE HOPE IS THAT
THIS AUTHORITY WILL HELP
ADDRESS OUR HOUSING CRISIS WE
CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM THE
STATE'S HIGHEST HOME PRICES.
RECORD RENTS RECORD EVICTIONS
AND RECORD HOMELESSNESS LEVELS.
THE LAST TIME WE WERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE IN MID JUNE THE
REGIONAL AGENCIES WERE IN THE
MIDST OF CONSIDERING
RECOMMENDING AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL. THAT WOULD CONVEY THE
SUPPORT OF A BROAD RANGE OF
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE BEER.
SINCE THAT TIME THE REGIONAL
AGENCIES HAVE CONCLUDED THE
PROCESS. AND IN JULY I'M
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THEY
VOTED TO SUPPORT THE BILL. WITH
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS BY A
VOTE OF TWENTY TO THREE. AT A
BAG THE ASSOCIATION BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS AND BY THIRTEEN
THREE VOTE. AT THE END TO SEE
THE MEASURE TO METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. WE
HAVE SINCE INCORPORATED THEIR
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH SENATOR
MCGUIRE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS.
THAT HE AND OTHERS HAVE ALSO
REYES WITH THE BILL. MANAGER
SHARE SOME OF THE HIGH LEVEL
DETAILS OF THE BILL. IN TERMS
OF GOVERNANCE. WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE CREATING A NEW REGIONAL
AGENCY OR BUREAUCRACY WITH THIS
BILL. INSTEAD ALL MAJOR
DECISIONS RELATED TO REVENUES
EXPENDITURES EXCEPT FOR WILL BE
MADE BOTH BY A BAG AN MTC. WITH
A BAG AS THE LEAD AGENCY. IN
TERMS OF REVENUE. THE SHARE
FUNDS TO BE DISTRIBUTED
DIRECTLY TO COUNTIES HAS BEEN
INCREASED BY FROM 75% TO AT
LEAST EIGHTY PERCENT.
REFLECTING THE DESIRE FOR
HIGHER RETURNS SOURCE. WITH THE
REMAINING 20% TO GO TO REGIONAL
POOL. THE EXCEPTION IS A
POTENTIAL TAX EMPLOYMENT WHERE
50% WOULD GO TO A REGIONAL
POLL. WHICH ENABLES OUR REGION
TO SUPPORT CITIES AT FACE THE
BURDEN OF HOUSING THE WORK
FORCE. WITHOUT TAX REVENUES
THAT THESE JOBS WOULD PROVIDE.
ADDITIONALLY THE THREE LARGEST
CITIES IN THE REGION WOULD GET
THEIR ALLOCATION OF FUNDS FOR
THEIR COUNTIES REFLECTING THEIR
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
BURDEN. OF BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. OTHER CITIES IN THE
REGION WOULD GET GUARANTEED
FUNDING OF THEY HAVE MORE THAN
30% OF THEIR COUNTIES LOAN
CAMINO NUMBERS. IN TERMS OF
EXPENDITURE. AT LEAST TWO
THIRDS OF THE FUNDING AT THE
REGIONAL COUNTY LEVELS MUST BE.
DEDICATED TO PRODUCTION AND
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND MONIES COULD ALSO
BE SPENT ON TENT PROTECTIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND STAFF
SUPPORT. WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THESE CHANGES. AND OUR REGION
WIDE COLLABORATION AND I WANT
TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
THE MANY STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AS WELL
AS ALL OF YOU. FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESS. FROM THE MTC REBEKAH
LAW. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO GOOD EVENING AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I'M THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS MANAGER
FOR M. T. C. AND A BAG. AND
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO REACH THIS
STAGE IN THIS LONG PROCESS WE
HAD A VERY COLLABORATIVE.
PROCESS AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL
THERE WERE A LOT OF CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL WHEN IT FIRST
WAS INTRODUCED BY MANY LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS INCLUDING. ON
MANY OF THEM ON OUR BOARD. WE
HAD AN AD HOC COMMITTEE THAT
FOCUSED ON THE GOVERNANCE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THAT IN
PARTICULAR WAS A VERY THORNY
ONE WHO'S GOING TO DO WHAT. WE
HAVE ONE STAFF THAT SERVES TWO
DIFFERENT BOARDS. AND
ULTIMATELY AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO DESCRIBED WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE BOTH BOARDS. ON MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT EVERY ASPECT.
OF THIS PROGRAM. AND SO WE HAD
A NUMBER OF SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS
THEY HAVE ALL BEEN INCORPORATED
ON WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU IN CENTER
MCGUIRE FOR WORKING CLOSELY ON
WITH OUR- OWN BOARD MEMBERS AND
WITH OTHER ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
THE REGION. ON TO GET TO THIS
POINT AND JUST HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND NURTURE
SUPPORT TONIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR THE BELT. PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION. HI GOOD
EVENING MEMBERS AS A LEGACY OF
CRANKS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF A
COLLEAGUE WHO WHO COULD
ACTUALLY BE HERE TONIGHT TO
REPRESENT THE CITIES OF. THREE
MONTHS OAKLAND AND BERKELEY. HI
FOR MANY TO HIS IS ON BEHALF OF
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SB AT HOME HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
EAST BAY SILICON VALLEY AS WELL
AS ENTERPRISE IN SUPPORT. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS LIST
BONTA IN BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BE INSTRUCTS PORT. THE CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE MULLIGAN ON BEHALF
OF MAYOR LONDON BRAID IN THE
CITY COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT. HOW DAVID ON BEHALF OF
THE BAY AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. CASEY NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE NEED TO CHAIR THIS. MAYBE
ONLY ONE CHAIR WITH LONG INCOME
BACK. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL GUNNING WITH
THE C. B. I A ONE OF MY
FAVORITE GOLF MOVIES IS
CADDYSHACK AND I FEEL LIKE THE
KID THAT THROUGH THE- ROOF DAY
BABY RUTH IN THE POOL RIGHT NOW.
COME IN COME IN HERE BUT- I
GUESS FOR ALL THAT OUR
MEMBERSHIP PARTICIPATED IN THE
IN THE CASA AGREEMENT. AND WE
LEFT THERE WITH THE IMPRESSION
THAT NEW HOUSING RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING WOULD NOT BE INCLUDED.
AS A TAX BASE FOR THIS AND SO
WHY ARE OPPOSITION HERE CENTERS
AROUND THAT. IN FACT I THINK IF
YOU LOOK AT PAGE THIRTEEN IT'S
SPECIFICALLY SAYS OF THE BILL.
THAT THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NEED TO THE REGION ACROSS
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPERS.
BUSINESSES ABOVE A CERTAIN SIDE
TAXPAYERS AND PROPERTY OWNERS
WITHIN THE REGION NOT
NECESSARILY NEW RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING. SO FOR ME THE US IS
DIFFICULT. CHAIRMAN CHOOSE A
FRIEND AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
COME TO AN AGREEMENT I THINK
OUR OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
REALLY HAS TO DEAL WITH IF
THERE'S A WAY TO CARVE OUT. NEW
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING THAT'S WHAT
OUR GOAL IS HERE AND CERTAINLY
WANT TO WORK WITH BOTH FUTURE
MCGUIRE AND YOU MISTER JUNIOR
TO FIGURE THAT OUT. OKAY THANK
YOU ALEX GIVES HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE TWO. MY APOLOGIES
OF COURSE THERE. AN OPPOSITION
GREAT THANK YOU YES ALEX GIVE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF DANVILLE PLEASANTON
LAFAYETTE AND WALNUT CREEK WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US BUT OUR
CONCERNS REALLY STAND WITH THE
RETURN TO SOURCE. THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION. OKAY WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SO IF I
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
AUTHOR AND I AND CENTER MCGUIRE
WERE ALL I TRY TO BE FOR THE
HEARING I AM GLAD AND I
UNDERSTAND THE BEING CAN DURING
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH CVI A
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
COULD YOU ME BABY SISTER
ELABORATE ON YOUR THINKING
AROUND THIS ISSUE CERTAINLY IN
ALSO A FEW THINGS I WAS JUST
PERSONALLY APPRISED OF THE
DETAILS OF THIS ISSUE REALLY A
FEW HOURS AGO I HAD BEEN HEARD
A FEW DAYS AGO THERE MIGHT BE
SOME QUESTIONS SAID BEEN
EXPECTING A PHONE CALL THE
WEEKEND IT DIDN'T HAPPEN HERE
WE ARE TODAY. A FEW THINGS IT
IS NOT BEEN OUR INTENT TO
TARGET AND TAX RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT WHAT I UNDERSTAND
WE'RE BEING ASKED TO DO IS TO
CARVE OUT OF THE APPLICATION OF
GENERAL TAXES FOR A SPECIFIC
SEGMENT THAT IS REPRESENTED BY
BY MR GUNNING AND I WILL SAY A
FEW THINGS ABOUT THAT FIRST
THIS BILL HAS BEEN A DISCUSSION
INTENSE DISCUSSION AROUND THE
BAY AND HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
A PORTION OF THIS IS VERY LAST
MINUTE WHAT I'D COMMITTED TO
THE PUBLIC WAS TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH A BAG AN EMPTY SEE
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING TODAY. THIS IS SIMPLY
JUST NOT AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
DISCUSSED I WISH THAT WE'VE HAD
TIME BUT BUT BUT WE DON'T
SECONDLY EIGHT THERE WAS A
SUGGESTION ABOUT WHAT WAS
DISCUSSED AT CASA AND
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WAS
DISCUSSED ACOSTA OR NOT THIS IS
THIS IS A STAND ALONE BILL THIS
BILL IS FRANKLY THAT MANY MANY
ELEMENTS OF IT ARE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT CASA WAS
ABOUT BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT POINT AND THEN I WOULD
JUST AND WITH. ITS TYPICALLY
VERY UNPRECEDENTED TO CARVE UT
AN INDUSTRY FROM AGAIN GENERAL
TAXATION I THINK WE SHOULDN'T
DO THAT LATELY I DO THINK
THERE'S A CONVERSATION WE HAD
AND I JUST WILL AND WITH THIS
POINT WHICH IS IT'S NOT MY
INTENT THAT IF THERE REVENUES
TO BE RAISED IN THE BAY AREA
FOR HOUSING THAT WE DO IT IN A
WAY THAT WOULD SOMEHOW. IMPEDE
NEW HOUSING CONSTRUCTION THAT
WOULD BE. COMPLETELY
COUNTERINTUITIVE SO I THINK WE-
SHARE THE SAME GOALS WHAT I
TOLD MR GOING. I IS IF WE DON'T
HAVE TIME TO FIGURE OUT THE MAN
THAT THAT MAKES SENSE ALL
PARTIES I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT. THAT I WE WOULD
BE WILLING IF WE CAN GET TO AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS. TO
CONSIDER A LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL THIS TOPIC AND A VERY
MUCH. WILL WILL CERTAINLY BE
WORKING. SEE TO SEE IF WE CAN
GET THERE BUT- THOSE ARE MY
COMMENTS. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
ALL TURNED OVER TO THE CENTER
MCGUIRE ON. I AND IT IS OBSERVE
A LAST MINUTE THING SO I AM. AS
SOMEONE WHO IS ALSO AN AUTHOR.
I UNDERSTAND THAT IS. A HARD.
ON I ALSO KNOW THAT YOUR
RECENTLY REPORT CAME OUT. A
MONTH AGO. SHOWING THE VERY
VERY HEAVY. OCT THE LOAD ON
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT AND
CALIFORNIA. WITH HUGE
DISPARITIES AMONG US CITIES
AND- I ENDING UP. MAKING
HOUSING MORE EXPENSIVE. AND SO
IT'S SOMETHING IS AN ISSUE THAT
I'M MINDFUL OF I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR IS MINDFUL OF A AND- SO
I. APPRECIATE YOU CONTINUING
THE AND NOT DIALOGUE TO SEE IF
THERE IS. A WAY TO RESOLVE
THOSE. SENATE MCGUIRE. SO MUCH
WAS THAT YOUR FIRST THOUGHT
WHEN I TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THINK OF THE CHAIR WHO IS. A
BEEN DEEPLY ENGAGED IN THIS
PROCESS TRAVELING. TO MEETINGS
TO ENSURE ALL OF US WERE AT THE
TABLE. WITH LOCAL ELECTED
LEADERS BY THE WAY IN TO SEE
NAY BAG ESTABLISH AN AD HOC
COMMITTEE. THAT MET WITH THE
CHAIR THE CHAIR OF ASSEMBLY
HOUSING MYSELF ON AND WE'VE HAD
MORE CONFERENCE CALLS IN PERSON
MEETINGS TO BE ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH THIS ISSUE. I WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AS
THE NUMBER TWO SIMILAR TO I IS
A WARRIOR. HE TAKES ON BIG
ISSUES LIKE THIS AT WITH
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDER HOLDERS
TRY TO DRIVE CONSENSUS NAY
BELIEVE WHAT YOU SEE IN FRONT
OF US TODAY. IS THE FRUITS OF A
CONSENSUS DRIVEN PROCESS AS HAD
MULTIPLE VOICES OF THE TYPE
TABLE AND BY THE WAY. FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS IN
ORGANIZATIONS. SO IF IT'S OKAY
MISTER CHAIR JUST SHARING
CANDIDLY SOME FRUSTRATION AS WE
SIT HERE TONIGHT AT TEN TO
EIGHT. WE HAVE BEEN VERY
CAUTIOUS WE BEING THE AUTHOR
THE CHAIR OF HOUSING IN MYSELF
ABOUT NOT. CREATING ANY TYPE OF
SIDE DEALS THE PROCESS THAT'S
BEEN ESTABLISHED BY AND HE'S
SEEN A BAG IS THAT DAY HAVE
APPOINTED AN AD HOC. THAT AD
HOC WOULD BRING BACK
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM WORKING
MEETINGS WHICH WOULD THEN BE
ADOPTED BY MTC METROPOLITANS
PETITION COMMISSION AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS. THERE'S BEEN DEEP
ENGAGEMENT BY THAT I AD HOC. WE
HAVE HAD DEEP ENGAGEMENT WITH
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS
EVERYTHING FROM NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPERS A FOR PROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPERS CITIES AND
COUNTIES TENETS. ORGANIZATIONS
YOU NAME IT THEY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS AND
WHILE WE HAVE NOT ALWAYS AGREED
ON ALL ISSUES WE WERE ABLE TO
COME TO THE AGREEMENT THAT YOU
SEE IN FRONT OF US HERE
TONIGHT. WE ESTABLISH A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS WITH DEEP
ENGAGEMENT FROM CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE BAY AREA BY
THE WAY. MULTIPLE VOICES WITH
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND AS WE
ALL KNOW ANYONE WHO'S BEEN
FOCUSED ON HOUSING. NOT EASY TO
DRIVE CONSENSUS. I WILL
CHARACTERIZE THIS IS A LAST
MINUTE BOND. AND QUITE FRANKLY
IT'S A LUDICROUS APPROACH. WE
HAVE. SO I WILL SPEAK FOR
MYSELF GOVERNS IN FINANCE. HI
THE CONSULTANT GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM
THIS ORGANIZATION WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT FOR THE REPRESENTATIVE
BECAUSE HE IS FANTASTIC WHAT HE
DOES. BUT FOR THE ORGANIZATION
WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM THEM.
THE FIRST THING THAT WE HEAR
FROM IS AN HOUR AGO. AN HOUR
AGO. THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
THERE HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE
OPPORTUNITIES BOTH WORKING WITH
CHAIR OF HOUSING UP FROM BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY INNOCENT. TO WORK
WITH US TO BE ABLE TO BE PART
OF THIS COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
NOT ONCE HAS THIS EVER HAPPENED
I CAN JUST SPEAK FOR MYSELF UP
FOR GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
THERE ARE ALSO PUBLIC MEETINGS
IN WHICH ORGANIZATIONS
PARTICIPATING OR COULD ATTENDED.
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN. SO I WANNA
MAKE A NOTE. THAT IN THIS BILL
IF THERE NEEDS TO BE A FURTHER
DISCUSSION ABOUT TAXES IT COULD
BE HAD AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. ALL
THIS BILL IS DOING. IS ALLOWING
THE VOTERS IN THE BAY AREA TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE A DECISION ON
REVENUE OPTIONS. IT IS
ESSENTIALLY A PROVIDES CHOICES
FOR A BAG IN IN DC TO BE ABLE
TO PICK AND CHOOSE FROM.
EVERYTHING THAT WOULD BE OUR IN
FOR EVERYTHING THAT IS IN FRONT
OF US TONIGHT WOULD ALL HAVE TO
BE VOTER APPROVED WHICH MEANS
THERE CAN BE. A IN DEPTH
DISCUSSIONS AT THE A BAG IN IN
DC LEVEL AND BY THE WAY BOTH
BOARDS HAVE TO APPROVE BEFORE
ANYTHING IS PUT ON THE BALLOT.
ON THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE. BUT
QUITE CANDIDLY I HAVE NO
APPETITE WITH A ONE HOUR NOTICE
PRIOR TO THIS WITH OPPOSITION
THE BILL TO TAKE ANYTHING UP
HERE THIS EVENING. AND OUR FOR
THE REST OF THE WEEK THIS IS.
LESS THAN LAST MINUTE NIGHT
WILL GET OFF THE FRUSTRATION
BOX HERE IN JUST SAY HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE BOTH AT THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND SENT OVER TO
FOR ALL THE WORK AND I DO LOOK
FOR TO BE IN A SIT DOWN C. B. I
A TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. THEY DO GREAT
WORK THERE ADVOCATING FOR
HOUSING. ACROSS THE STATE BUT
ON THIS ONE ISSUE I HAVE TO
DISAGREE. I CENTERS SKINNER
THANK YOU. BUT WE'VE ALL BEEN
IN THIS KIND OF CIRCUMSTANCE
NONE OF US LIKE TO BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN WORKED ON FOR. CLOSE
TO A YEAR NOW. GETS A LAST
MINUTE OPPOSITION LETTER THAT.
FROM FROM AN ORGANIZATION THAT
IS BOTH RESPECTED AND CARRIES
CONSIDERABLE WEIGHT BUT THE
THING THAT I WANT TO CLARIFY IS
SO MISTER WHERE YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN REFERENCING THIS BUT- AS
FAR AS I UNDERSTAND IT. THIS
BILL IT'S NOT JUST THAT
SOMETHING HAS TO HAVE VOTER
APPROVAL BUT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS OFF THE RICE. MT SEEN A
BACK. TO DEVELOP VOTER
MEASURES. AND THEY COULD ANY
GIVES THEM THE TYPE OF. OF TAX
POSSIBILITIES BUT IT DOES NOT
SAY. AND THIS IS WHERE I WANT
YOU TO CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
FOR EXAMPLE IF THEY WERE TO
CHOOSE IF THEY WERE TO PUT
FORWARD SAY A PROPERTY TAX
MEASURE. THAT WERE INCLUDE
PROPERTY TAXES IF THEY WERE TO
CHOOSE THAT IT WOULD NOT BE
INCLUDED ON ANY EITHER NEW.
HOME CONSTRUCTION OR-
SIGNIFICANT. ADDITIONS TO YOU
I'M JUST. THE CARD EXACTLY THE
TYPE OF THING WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE OTHER WAYS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO BOTH FACILITATE GREEN
LIGHT AND STREAMLINE HOUSING BY
EITHER TRYING TO CAPPER LIMIT
FEES OR GIVE SOME TAX
EXEMPTIONS AND SUCH AS FAR AS I
CAN TELL THIS BILL DOES NOT
TIED THE HANDS OF THE BACK ROOM
AND TO SEE IN TERMS OF PUTTING
IN. THE KIND OF EXEMPTION THAT
WILL BE A MIGHT BE ADVOCATING
FOR CORRECT YOU ARE ENTIRELY
CORRECT OKAY SO GIVEN THAT IN
AYE I APPRECIATE THEIR RAISING
THE POINT. BECAUSE I THINK IT
AT LEAST I IS A BAY AREA MEMBER
ESPECIALLY ONE WHERE I KNOW WE
HAVE CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
COST TO CONSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW
ANYWHERE BUT THE BERRY HAS EVEN
HIGHER COST OF CONSTRUCTION AND
THE REST TO CALIFORNIA. SO
CLEARLY WE DON'T WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING TO. TWO MAKING IT
WORSE AND WE ALREADY ARE SEEING
NOW ON WOULD YOU CALL IT
PROJECTS THAT ARE THAT HAVE
PERMITS ARE FULLY ENTITLED
ENORMOUS NOT STARTING
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE AGAIN
THEY'RE FINANCING IS IT'S JUST
NOT MAKING SENSE RIGHT. SO
ANYWAY SO MY POINT BEING THAT.
THE BILL STILL ALLOWS FOR WHAT
WAS ADVOCATED WITHOUT OUR
HAVING TO AMEND OR FIX IT. NOW
SECONDARILY. I AM GLAD THAT IT
DOES NOT. MY I'M TIRED FROM THE
LONG DAY LC DICTATE I DON'T
USUALLY WOULDN'T USUALLY USE
THAT TERM BUT IT DOESN'T
DICTATE WHAT TYPES OF REVENUE
MEASURES THE IT'S IT PUTS
AROUND YEAR ROUND YOU CAN HERE
ARE WHAT YOU HAVE OPTION FOR
BUT IT DOESN'T DICTATE YOU MUST
DO THIS WHEN YOU MUST DO THAT
ONE. AND I'M VERY GLAD ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT A
LOT OF SALES TAX. AND WE'VE GOT
EVERY COMMUNITY IN COUNTY IN
OUR DISTRICT TALKING ABOUT
EXTRA. EXTRA SALES TAXES FOR
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN WE
HAVE OUR SAME AREA WARNING
SALES TAX FOR REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION MEASURES AND WE-
AND A CERTAIN POINT AND- I
PROBABLY ALREADY. WE ARE BEYOND
WHAT WE CAN HANDLE SALES TAX SO
I'M VERY GLAD IT DOESN'T
DICTATE IT BECAUSE THERE ARE
CERTAIN. TAXES THAT. I WOULD
NOT BE SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT. I AM
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL
AND OF CREATING THIS. AUTHORITY
AND ABILITY TO PURSUE IT BUT I
WILL BE WATCHING VERY CAREFULLY
WHAT IS EXACTLY STRUCTURED
BECAUSE I THINK THAT GIVEN THE
INCOME. DISCREPANCIES IN OUR
AREA AND THE COST OF HOUSING IN
OUR AREA THAT WHATEVER IS
DESIGNED REALLY NEEDS TO BE AS
LESS REGRESSIVE AS POSSIBLE.
BUT ANYWAY I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL AND SPECIALLY YOU SEVEN
NUMBER TWO FOR. BEING
PERSISTENT HONEST WORKING SO
HARD ON IT AND I WANT TO THANK
THE- ALL OF THE ENTITIES IN THE
BAY AREA STARTING WITH CASA AND
THEN CONTINUING ON TOO MANY
MORE. WHO HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW
CREATED TO CONDITION THE EVEN
ALLOW THIS TO GET TO THE POINT
WHERE IT IS TODAY. AND WITHOUT
IT WILL BE SUPPORTING IT. THANK
YOU AND I JUST. I FIRST OF ALL
OBVIOUSLY IT WOULD ROOM YOU
KNOW I DO OF. IF WE IF WE THE
ISSUE A BAN. RAISED A FEW WEEKS
AGO NOT. A DISPUTING THAT BURKE
REGARDLESS OF THE TIMING. AND
I. AND I AGREE WITH THOSE
CENTER MCGUIRE AND CENTER
SKINNER. THAT HAVING FLEX THE
DISS FLEXIBILITY FOR WHAT THE-
REGION WILL DECIDE TO DO. AND
OF COURSE IF THERE IS ACTIVE.
OPPOSITION TO ANY YOU KNOW
REVENUE MEASURE. THAT'S ALWAYS
PROBLEMATIC AND SO CLEARLY
THERE WILL BE LOVERS AND HAVING
THOSE DISCUSSIONS LOCALLY. BUT
I DO I DON'T WANT IT TO GET
LOST BY THE LATE OPPOSITION.
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE. YOU
KNOW IN IN OURS. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE AROUND
HOUSING. IS THAT. WE DON'T TAX
LONG TERM. PROPERTY OWNERS THE
OTHER PASS. DRAMATICALLY REDUCE
PROPERTY TAXES AND WHAT WE END
UP TAXING IS. ODD BOTH OUR NEW
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION
DOCKETS HEAVILY TAXED VIA AND
IMPACT FEES AND THE NEW
HOMEOWNERS BECAUSE THEY GOT TAX
THE MARKET RATE UNDER PROP
THIRTEEN. SO WE HAVE THIS
SYSTEM WHERE WE YOU KNOW SAY
NEW HOMEOWNERS THE TAX LAW AND
HOMES THAT DON'T EVEN HAVE
PEOPLE LIVING IN THEM YET. THE
TAX LAW. AND SO IT IS IT IS A
REAL ISSUE AND SO AGAIN THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR GREEN TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION. AND.
WITH THAT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS JUST CENTER MICHAEL
SKI. THE BEARER PERSON ALL
MOVED TO THE MEASURE BUT I
WANTED TO DRIVE OUR ATTENTION
BACK TO PAGE THIRTEEN BECAUSE.
FOUR SIX FOUR SIX FOUR SIX
HUNDRED. HE SEE SAYS IT'S THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
THE FUNDING AS THE CHAIR POINTS
OUT SHE COME FROM COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPERS BUSINESSES OF
CERTAIN SIZE TAXPAYERS AND
PROPERTY OWNERS ACROSS THE
REGION SO AGAIN IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT IT THE MEASURE ELOQUENTLY
GIVES THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES SAY
BANK AND AN MTC THE AUTHORITY
THAT THE TO PUT ON A MEASURE
HOWEVER THEY STRUCTURE THAT
WHICH IS WE LIKE TO HAVE THAT
LOCAL CONTROL IN IT DOESN'T
BALI BUT IT AND- IT LAYS OUT
THE INTENT WHICH DOESN'T
INCLUDE WHAT THIS LETTER SAYS
ARE LOOPHOLES IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE ANY THAT THERE'S A
SINGLE. TAX NEW CONSTRUCTION IT.
SPECIFICALLY DOESN'T CALL THAT
OUT SO. I KNOW THIS IS A LATE
HOUR I DON'T WHEN I READ THE
OPPOSITION LETTER AND I READ
THAT PLAIN TEXT AND I KNOW THAT
THE PROCESS IS FOR. THE
REGIONAL AGENCIES TO PUT THIS
ON. AM I MISSING HERE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THESE DO YOU SEE
ANYWHERE IN HERE THIS
SPECIFICALLY CALLS OUT FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION TO FOOT THE BILL
HERE FOR THE EAST FOR A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT I DON'T AND THAT'S
WHY I AM STILL FRANKLY AS I'VE
EXPRESSED TO SEE A STILL A
LITTLE MYSTIFIED AS TO EXACTLY
WHAT THE OBJECTION IS BECAUSE
WE ARE NOT SAYING IN THIS BILL
THEY'LL SHELL TAX RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPERS. WERE ST WE MAY TAX
BUSINESSES OVER CERTAIN SIZE
TAXPAYERS PROPERTY OWNERS
EXCEPT TRUCK BUT WERE NOT
SPECIFICALLY TAXING THAT ENTITY
BUT THEIR CONCERN IS IF THEY'RE
NOT SPECIFICALLY CARVED OUT FOR
MORE GENERAL TAX THAT THEY
WOULD BE BEARING ATTACKS THAT
IS GONNA BE APPLIED GENERALLY.
I THINK IT'S A CONVERSATION WE
CAN HAVE AN AGAIN AS I SAID I
REMEMBER ONE HAVE IT IF WE
BELIEVE AS THE CHAIRMAN HAS
INDICATED THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
OVERTAXED WITH THOSE ARGUMENTS
BE COMPELLING IN FRONT OF HIM
TO SEE IN A BAG WHEN THEY WERE
CONSIDERING A REGIONAL TAP I
THINK IT VERY WELL COULD AND AS
THE GOOD CENTER FOR BERKELEY
POINTED OUT THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
DISCUSSION THAT CAN HAPPEN
BETWEEN A BAG AND THE FTC WHEN
THEY CONSIDER. WHAT THEY WANTED
TO AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE NOT BE
PRESCRIPTIVE WERE PROVIDING A
NUMBER OF OPTIONS AND ALSO JUST
BE ABUNDANTLY CLEAR AS CENTER
SKINNER SAID ALLUDED TO WE
SPECIFICALLY TOOK OUT THE SALES
TAX IS ONE OF THE OPTIONS
BECAUSE WE HEARD FROM ALL OF
COUNTIES THAT THAT IS NOT AN
OPTION THEY WANT TO PROVIDE. TO
THE NIGHT COUNTY REGION SO
MOVING TRAIL. OKAY WITH MOTION
THAT. QUESTIONS ABOUT YES AND
REBATES. YEAH HI I'M- LOOKING
AT PAGE THIRTEEN AND. SO I
WOULDN'T THINK THAT BE I A IS
NOT FAR OFF YOU OF THIS
PARTICULAR STATEMENT IN THE
INTENT SAYS PROPERTY OWNERS
WITHIN THE REGION. THOSE COULD
BE PROPERTY OWNERS WHO HAVE
ENTITLEMENTS RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT AND THEREFORE THEY
WOULD BE SUBJECT BILL LEFT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THEY'RE GONNA
SPECIFICALLY BE CARVED OUT. AND
THAT'S A LOT OF. THAT'S A LOT
OF FAITH TO PUT IN AN ODD TO
WHAT GOES ON AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EXCUSE ME AND I'VE
THOUGHT ON THEM FOR YEARS AND
YEARS. SO I THINK THEY HAVE A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN OVER THAT
THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED GOING
FORWARD SECONDLY. I THINK THAT
MIGHT BE A LITTLE HARSH TO BE
JUMPING ALL OVER THEM WHEN IN
THEIR OWN LETTER. ARE THEY THEY
SAY THAT IN JULY THEY RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT. WHAT WAS BEING
BROUGHT FORWARD SO I'M NOT I AM
JUST SAYING I THINK TONIGHT YOU
GUYS BEEN A LOT OF TIME A LOT
OF COMPROMISE CONVERSATIONS.
BUT I THINK THAT THEY'RE JUST
ASKING AND MAYBE IT IS A LITTLE
TOO LATE I DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
AMENDMENTS CAME. WERE PUT INTO
THE BILL AND WHEN THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THEM. BUT I
THINK THEY RAISE SERIOUS
CONCERNS HOW THIS CAN BE.
MANAGED WHEN HE GETS OUT TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND HOW IT'S
ADDRESSED BY THE PARTNERS TO
DOUBT. TO THOSE. AREAS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND I'VE
THIRD. PROBABLY TOO LONG TWENTY
TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVELS THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WHEN YOU'VE GOT
THAT KIND OF A LOOPHOLE YOU
JUST KIND OF PUT YOUR FORTUNE
ON THE TABLE IN FRONT OF A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT
SHARE THE SAME. CONCERNS THAT
YOU HAVE REGARDING PROPERTY
RIGHTS THAT YOU CURRENTLY WERE
GIVEN THREE YEAR ENTITLEMENT SO
I JUST THROW THAT OUT FOR A
DISCUSSION AND MAYBE GOING FOR
WE DO TAKE A DEEPER LOOK AT
THAT TO NOT I COULDN'T SUPPORT
IT. VERY YOU KNOW BASED ON THAT
ALONE. APPRECIATE THE
PERSPECTIVE ALSO A FEW THINGS
JUST SIMPLE PROCESS. I DO
UNDERSTAND THERE WAS. THERE WAS
RELEASED A CONVERSATION TO WITH
MY STAFF. I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THERE WERE SOME
MISUNDERSTANDINGS BETWEEN BOTH
SIDES OF WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
GET OUT. IT WASN'T REYES WITH
ME I AND- AND THE CHAIRMAN OF
THIS COMMITTEE SOME REQUIRED I
WE WERE ALL VERY DEEPLY GAUGE
FOR MANY MANY MONTHS AND NO AND
IT BROUGHT IT TO. TO OUR
ATTENTION BUT PUT THE PUTTING
THAT ASIDE. IN ALSO APPRECIATE
YOUR POINT AROUND PROPERTY
OWNERS AROUND THE REGION YES IT
IS POSSIBLE. THAT CITY I
MEMBERS COULD BE IN THAT
SUBSET. I THINK THE POINT HERE
IS IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A CAR
ABOUT. OF ANY THESE GENERAL
TAXES BECAUSE OF THIS LENGTHY
PROCESS WE WENT THROUGH. THAT
CARVING OUT ONE INDUSTRY IS
LIKE PULLING OUT THE STRING.
BECAUSE EVERY OTHER INDUSTRY
SECTOR THAT DOESN'T WANT YOU
TAX WILL BE ASKING FOR THE SAME
THING AND SO THE IDEA WAS. WE
THOUGHT WAS FAIRLY SAY GIVE THE
REGION THE OPTION CONSUMER
GENERAL TAX. IT'S UP TO THEM TO
DECIDE WHO IT WOULD APPLY TO
AND THAT IS THE INTENT. BUT
THAT BEING SAID YOUR FIRST
POINT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN THIS COUNTRY SO I
WOULD JUST ASK THAT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROPERTY OWNERS
WHO HAVE CURRENT ENTITLEMENTS
FOR SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENTIAL.
THAT HAS TO BE DISCUSSED OR
YOU'VE GOT A HUGE LOOPHOLE
HERE. SPECIFICALLY AND- YOU
KNOW GENERALLY. THERE'S NO
QUESTION BECAUSE GOVERNMENTS
THAT CURRENTLY. HAVE ZONING ON
THOSE PROPERTIES THAT WILL BE
IN YOUR REGION. THEY CURRENTLY
HAVE ENTITLEMENTS. THIS EITHER
COMMERCIAL. FOR IS GOING TO BE
RESIDENTIAL MY THE MULTI FAMILY.
BUT IF THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
TAXING RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES.
AND THEY BELIEVE THEY WERE NOT
GOING TO BE INCLUDED. THAT
WOULD SEEM TO ME YOU'D USE THE
ENTITLEMENT APPROACH. HI
BECAUSE YOU CAN. YOU KNOW AND
THAT WAS ONLY CAN CHANGE. BUT
SERIOUSLY THAT LEFT THAT'S A
HUGE LOOPHOLE IN A BY. I'M JUST
THINKING ABOUT THE LAST MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT OF SOUTH. COUNTY IS
CALLED THE RANCH. YET IT HAS
ENTITLEMENTS FOR. HER SO I
REMEMBER THIS RIGHT JOHN IS
ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND HOMES
AND THERE'S MULTI FAMILY.
THERE'S COMMERCIAL WITHIN THAT
THAT IS ALL SET OUT IN A MAJOR
GENERAL PLAN IF YOU WOULD
EXPECT. WELL IF THAT YOU KNOW
THINKING ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
TAX THAT MANY SINGLE FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL HOMES IN THAT HUGE
DEVELOPMENT. BECAUSE SHE WANTED
MORE AFFORDABLE OR WHATEVER TO
FULL HUGE EMPOWER. INDIVIDUALS
AND THEY NEED TO GO TO MARKET
TO GET FINANCING WHATEVER.
THEY'VE GOT HEALTH SOME
PREDICTABILITY. AND I THINK
THAT THAT. IS SOMETHING I'M
JUST SAYING YOU KNOW TONIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THE
DECISION. ON. THIS BILL AND A
LITTLE THE GOVERNOR BUT YOU
GUYS NEED TO KEEP WORKING ON
NOW. IT'S GOING TO BE I THINK
VERY DIFFICULT WHEN IT GETS TO
THE LEVEL OF A BACK. AND I'VE
SAT ON YOU KNOW REGIONAL.
PLANNING. ORGANIZATION LIKE
THAT I'M JUST SUGGESTING THAT
APPRECIATE WERE CERTAINLY BEAT
IT TO DEATH CERTAINLY GONNA
KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING
AGAIN IF WE IF WE TAKE OUT ONE
SEGMENT OF PROPERTY OWNERS THE
SEGMENT THAT'S LEFT IS GOING TO
HAVE REAL ISSUE SO THAT'S HARD.
AND THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY
IS THIS WILL GET DISCUSSED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND IF FOR
EXAMPLE OF THE CBA LOCAL
COUNTERPARTS RACES ISSUE AND
SAID THEY WOULD OPPOSE A
REVENUE MEASURE. I HAVE A
FEELING AND TO SEE NAY BACK
WILL THINK EIGHT TIMES BEFORE
MOVING FOR WITH THAT BECAUSE WE
KNOW TO GET A TWO THIRDS VOTE
IN A REGION LIKE THIS. REALLY
DOES. REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
CONSENSUS AND THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA BE PUSHING FOR.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES. OKAY
SEEING NINE SOME OF THE ROAD
LIKE TO CLOSE LET ME JUST CLOSE
BY RETIRING TWO THINGS FIRST
DINNER DRINK SOME MAY. AND THEN
SECONDLY I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU FOR YOUR DEEP GAUGE MEANT
EVERYONE ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
BUT IN PARTICULAR THE CHAIRMAN
WHO SPENT MANY MANY HOURS
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS. AND
THE CHAIRMAN OF GOV AND
FINANCES SPENT MANY MANY MANY
MANY MANY MANY HOURS ON THIS AS
WELL AS EVERY FOR HIM TO SEE IN
A BACK ON THIS AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR PHONE.
OKAY I AGAIN RECOMMENDING AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE. HOUSE
HE- WITH. AND WITHOUT WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION TO
PASS TO GOVERN FINANCE. RIGHT.
FOR US RIVERSIDE. OKAY THE
MOTION IS THE PASTOR FOR. BUY
ME DRINKS TONIGHT. THIS IS AN
ABLE FORTY EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SOMEONE NUMBER TWO THE MOTION
IS AT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED
TO THE SENATE FOR CONSIDERATION
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER AYE
MORRELL BATES BATES NO CAMARO.
CAMARO I DRAWS OKAY. RUSSELL I
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE BARLACH.
ROUGH ROUGH I SKINNER SKINNER I
AM BURKE CASKEY FIVE BECAUSE HE
AYE THANK YOU CENTERS WE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR
UMBERG
. RIGHT YEAH. WHAT WE'RE.
OKAY GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE
THE VOTERS SEVEN THE ONE THE
MOTION PASSES. AND WE'RE
INSURANCE